Transcriber: Rıza Özdemir
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Benim çocukluğum her sabah kahvaltısında
annem ve babamla
açık radyo dinleyerek geçti.
Fonda Ömer Madra’nın sesi;
böylesine güzel,
bereketli bir dünyada yaşamanın
mutluluğunu kalbimde hissettiğimi,
bir yandan da onun kaynaklarını
nasıl böyle yanlış
ve bencilce kullandığımızı
sorguladığımı hatırlıyorum.
Bu sorgulamalarımla büyüdüm
ve sorularıma cevap bulabileceğim
bir yol aramaya başladım.
Lise yıllarımda biyoloji, coğrafya
derslerinde biz insanların yaratımı olan
iklim krizini daha detaylı öğrendim.
Dünyanın geleceği için endişem çocukluk
sorgulamalarım ile buluştu
ve kendime sordum:
Peki benim elimden ne gelir?
Böylelikle iklim aktivistliği
yolculuğum başladı.
Türkiye'de iklim grevleri düzenledim.
İklim krizi konusunda
okudum, yazdım, konuştum.
2019 yazında Lozan’da düzenlenen
Avrupa Genç İklim Aktivistleri
buluşmasında Türkiye’yi temsil ettim
ve iklim aktivisti Ferat Atılgan ile
birlikte Birleşmiş Milletler’e
gönderdiğimiz iklim için gençlik
manifestosunu hazırladık.
İklim Hareketi’nin yıllar süren
mücadelesi sonucunda
önemli kazanımlarımız oldu.
Örneğin Türkiye, 2021 yılında Paris
İklim Anlaşması’nı meclisten geçirdi
ve 2050′ye kadar küresel sıcaklık artışını
2 derecenin altında tutmak için
üzerine düşeni yapmaya söz verdi.
Sonra sıra benim için üniversite
ve bölüm seçimine geldi.
Amerika’nın New Haven kentindeki
Yale Üniversitesinden kabul aldım
ve insanın doğaya verdiği zararı
en aza indirecek bir sistem hayaliyle
çıktım yola.
İlk senemde bir bölüm seçimi yapmadım,
ilgimi çeken farklı alanları
keşfetmek istedim.
Bir gün kimya laboratuvarındaki dersime
doğru yürürken bir binanın önünden geçtim.
Üzerindeki güneş panelleri
hemen ilgimi çekti.
İçine girip gezdim.
Enerji tasarrufu sağlayan hareket
sensörleri, kompost kutularıyla
yeşil mimari ilkelerini benimseyen bu
bina Yale Çevre Fakültesi idi.
Üniversite yıllarımı bu binanın içinde
nasıl projeler yapıldığını keşfederek
geçirmek istediğime karar verdim
ve bölümlerimi seçtim,
çevre ve enerji araştırmaları.
Gençler artık gelecekleri için endişeli.
Gençler artık gıdaya, suya, enerjiye
erişim konusunda meslekleri ne olursa
olsun zorluk çekeceklerini farkında.
Bu yüzden artık benim gibi birçok genç
iklim krizini çözmek için
çalışmak istiyor.
Peki neden?
Çünkü iklim krizini konuşmak
artık bir seçenek değil.
Bu bizim geleceğimizi kurtarma
mücadelemiz.
Çünkü durum gerçekten vahim.
2021 küresel iklim durumu raporuna göre
son yedi yıl kayda geçen
en sıcak yedi yıl oldu.
Üstelik iklim krizi, sadece küresel
sıcaklık artışıyla sınırlı
bir tehdit değil.
Amazon ormanlarının %17′sinden
fazlasını daha şimdiden kaybettik.
Grönland’daki buz tabakasında son 25
yıldır üst üste net azalma gözlendi
ve deniz seviyeleri hiç olmadığı
kadar yükseldi.
Sel, orman yangını gibi felaketlerin hızı
son otuz yılda üç katına çıktı
ve bu felaketler sırasında her yıl 20
milyon iklim mülteci ise evini terk etmek
zorunda kalıyor.
Her gün yüz elli canlı
türünü kaybediyoruz
ve 65 milyon yıldır benzeri görülmemiş bu
felakete bilim insanları
altıncı kitlesel
yok oluş ismini veriyorlar.
Yani yerküreyi o kadar hızlı
değiştiriyoruz ki, içinde bulunduğumuz
çağın artık yeni bir ismi var: Androposen.
Yani İnsan Çağı.
Bu çağa kadar iklim koşulları insanlığın
tarihini belirliyordu.
Ama artık insanlar iklimin
tarihini belirliyor.
Peki bu noktaya nasıl geldik?
Bahsettiğimiz bütün bu felaketlerin çıkış
noktası aslında bu piramitteki hata,
insanın doğa üzerindeki
hak ve üstünlük iddiası.
Tarih kitaplarına açıkça şöyle yazmalıyız.
İnsan bencil davrandı, bütün dünyayı
kontrol edebileceğini sandı
ve kendi teknolojik ilerlemesi için
fosil yakıtları yani kömürü, petrolü,
doğalgazı durmak bilmeden kullandı.
Hem de gelecek nesilleri hiç düşünmeden.
Hem de doğaya verdiği zararı bile bile.
Bu sistemde ciddi bir tasarım hatası var.
Şimdi, sorunları tespit ettik.
Peki, bu krizden çıkış mümkün mü?
Evet, mümkün
ama önce bir konuda hemfikir olalım,
bu değişim kolay ve acısız olmayacak.
Mevcut ekonomik sistemimizi aynı tutarak,
konfor alanımızdan ödün vermeyerek
bu krizi çözemeyiz.
Biliyorum, bu gerçeği duymak
istemiyorsunuz.
Yeşil vaatlerde bulunup içini doldurmayan
yeşile boyama kampanyalarıyla şirketler
veya iklim aksiyonu yalnızca sözde
bırakan politikacılar da
bu gerçeğin farkında.
Bu yüzden bize eğer plastiğin bizi geri
dönüştürüyor ya da pamuklu ürünleri
tercih edersek dünyayı kurtarabileceğimiz
masalını anlatmaya devam ediyorlar.
Gelecek teknolojilerin iklim krizini
çözmeye yeteceği inancı, hemen bugün
sistemsel dönüşüme hayatın her alanında
başlamamızın önünü kesiyor.
Fakat üniversitede aldığım dersler
bana net bir şekilde gösterdi,
bu krizi çözecek tek bir
sihirli değnek yok.
Dünyamızı kurtarmak için teknolojiye
bel bağlamak bir çözüm değil.
Çünkü ihtiyacımız olan insanı ekosistemin
en tepesine yerleştiren
bu paradigmanın değişikliği.
Büyüme odaklı mentalitemizi
değiştirmediğimiz sürece
hiçbir teknoloji bu krizi
kendi başına çözemez.
Politik ve ekonomik dönüşüm olmadan yeni
teknolojiler bu krizi tedavi edemez.
İşte bu yüzden sizin, benim gibi farklı
alanlarda çalışan insanların yaratacağı
değişime ihtiyacımız var.
Tıpkı üniversitede aldığım dersler gibi,
farklı disiplinlerde yeşil dönüşümü nasıl
sağlayacağımızı düşünmeliyiz.
Sosyal yaşantımızın hemen her alanını
yeniden tasarlamamız gerekiyor.
Eğitim bu dönüşüme başlamak
için harika bir alan.
Dönüştürmemiz gereken ilk alan
bu yüzden eğitim.
İklim ve çevre bilimi
eğitiminin okul yaşantısının önemli bir
parçası olması gerekiyor.
Öğrenciler ileride bunun mesleğini
yapsınlar diye değil, kendi hayatlarında
bu doğrultuda değerler ve alışkanlıklar
kazansınlar diye.
Hatta çevre eğitimi
sadece sınıfta kalmamalı.
Çocukların toprakla çalışarak, kuşların
seslerini dinleyerek, doğanın bir parçası
olduğumuzu hissederek büyümesi ne
şahane olur, bir düşünsenize.
Lise yıllarımda organik tarım öğrenmek
benim bakış açımı değiştiren
bir deneyimdi.
İklim eğitimi alanında hem Türkiye'de hem
de dünyada çok güzel gelişmeler var.
Örneğin benim yönetim kurulunda olduğum
Yuvam Dünya Derneği,
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı ile iklim krizine
müfredatın bir parçası hâline getirmek
için çalışmalar yapıyor.
Dünyada ise Amerika’da
Stanford Sürdürülebilirlik Fakültesi
John Doerr’un 1 milyar dolarlık bağışı ile
Eylül 2022′de açılıyor.
Bu gelişmeler umut verici ama bu
güzel örnekleri
hızla yaygınlaştırmamız gerekiyor.
Dönüştürmemiz gereken ikinci alan ekonomi.
Yeni, sürdürülebilir ve ekonomik sistemi
hep beraber tasarlamamız gerekiyor.
Burada sürdürülebilirlik
ile ne kastediyorum?
Öyle bir sistem tasarlayalım ki
kendi kendini devam ettirebilsin.
Dünyanın sınırlı kaynağı var ve o
kaynaklar bittiğinde sistem çökecek.
Yani sınırsız büyüme bir illüzyon,
sürdürülebilir ekonomi,
sınırsız büyümeye karşı
kendi kendine yetebilen bir
ekonomik anlayışı benimsiyor.
İşte bu döngüsel ekonomi, iklim aktivisti
yolculuğumda çok değerli bir yeri olan
Uygar Özesmi ise buna Türetim
Ekonomisi ismini veriyor.
Ekolojik ve sosyal açıdan adil
üreticilerden alışveriş yapabildiğimiz
Good4trust isimli online platformu
Türkiye’de döngüsel ekonomi
için atılan şahane bir adım.
Tüketiciler olarak bize düşen ise bu tarz
sosyal girişimleri desteklemek.
Ekonomik dönüşüm elbette bedava değil,
oldukça pahalı.
Yeşil ekonomik dönüşüm için küresel
ekonominin her yıl 3 buçuk trilyon dolar
harcaması gerekiyor.
Fakat aksi senaryo çok daha endişe verici.
İklim krizi için bugün aksiyon almamak
gelecek yıllarda küresel ekonomiye tam
178 trilyon dolara mal olacak.
Sizce hangi seçenek daha kârlı?
Dünyanın en zengin 10 iş insanının toplam
servetinin 1 trilyon dolardan fazla
olduğunu düşününce, dünyamızı kurtarmak
için 3 buçuk trilyon
pek de fazla görünmüyor.
Dönüştürmemiz gereken üçüncü
alan politika.
Enerji sistemimizi sürdürülebilir hâle
getirecek altyapıya
ve teknolojiye sahibiz.
En büyük eksiğimiz politik
irade ve aksiyon.
Dünyanın en zengin 10 şirketi ve ülkesi
bu dönüşüm için gerekli finansmanı bir
hafta içerisinde sağlayabilir.
Ama kimse bu dönüşümün liderliğini
yapacak cesarete sahip değil.
Bu da politikaya hantallaştırıyor ve
liderlik krizini beraberinde getiriyor.
İklim krizi neden politik bir mesele?
Çünkü bu kriz herkesi eşit
derecede etkilemiyor.
Yerel halklar, yoksul topluluklar
ve kadınlar çok daha büyük
bir tehdit altında.
Üstelik, bu toplulukların karar alıcı
pozisyonlardaki temsiliyeti çok az.
İklim krizine karşı savunmasız konumda
olan bu toplulukların karar alma
mekanizmalarına dahil edildiği
yeni bir sorumlu liderlik anlayışına
ihtiyacımız var.
Şimdi sorunları tespit ettik.
Ne yapılması gerektiğini de biliyoruz.
Peki neden değişime bu kadar direniyoruz?
Ece Temelkuran’ın harekete geçme
isteksizliğimiz hakkında
harika bir metaforu var,
ip atlayan küçük kızın korkusu.
Şimdi sanki atlama sırası bize
geldi ve biz donduk kaldık.
Pandemi, savaşlar, iklim krizi aslında
aynı hastalığın farklı semptomları.
Bu eş zamanlı çoklu felaketler bize
sistemde bir hata olduğunu gösteriyor.
Çok güvendiğimiz kapitalist
sistem artık hata veriyor.
Ama biz bunu bir değişim fırsatı olarak
görmek yerine hep eski güzel günlere
bakıyor ve bir normale dönüş
hayalini kovalıyoruz.
Güvenli kozamızdan konfor alanımızdan
çıkmak istemiyoruz.
Harekete geçmek için cesaret bekliyoruz.
Ama cesaret bize dışarıdan
verilebilecek bir şey değil.
Bizim içimizde büyütmemiz gereken bir his.
Her şeyden önce bizim değişmeyi
sahiden istememiz gerekiyor.
Kozamızdan çıkmak bir cesaret meselesi.
Dünyada görmek istediğimiz değişimi
hemen bugün etki
yaratabileceğimiz alanlardan
başlayabiliriz.
Birincisi, hepimiz tüketiciler olarak
ihtiyacımız olmadıkça almayarak ve satın
alırken sürdürülebilirliğe önem veren
markaları
tercih ederek döngüsel
ekonomiye geçişe katkı sağlayabiliriz.
Vatandaşlar olarak iklim eğitimine ve
katılımcı politikaya önem veren
politikacılar için oy kullanabilir veya
iklim aktivisti grupların parçası olarak
sistemsel dönüşüm için taleplerimizi
mevcut politikacılara iletebiliriz.
Hayal ettiğimiz dönüşümü hemen bugün
evimizde, okulumuzda,
iş yerimizde uygulayarak başlayabiliriz.
Unutmayın, küçük su damlaları
bir araya geldiğinde dünyamızı saran
bu kocaman yangını söndürebilir.
Benim değişim için size önerim şu.
Hayatın her alanına bir iklim aktivistinin
eleştirel gözlükleriyle bakın
ve yeteneklerinizi, deneyimlerinizi bu
krizi yavaşlatacak projeler için kullanın.
Göreceksiniz ki değiştirecek çok şey var.
Değişimi isteme cesaretini
göstermeye var mısınız?
Teşekkür ederim.